tanto como la deportación a sus países
de origen sin embargo la patrulla
fronteriza del Valle del Río Grande a
través de su Jefa Gloria Chávez informó
que en el marco del final del título 42
fueron aprendidas 1900 personas de las
cuales 1800 están ya siendo procesadas
por el nuevo título 8 Aunque sus
deportaciones se realizarán a territorio
mexicano en lugar de los países de
origen como lo estipula la norma con la
implementación de Este título 8 que
usted menciona Qué opciones le quedan
ahora a los miles de migrantes
actualmente varados en Ciudad Juárez y
otras ciudades fronterizas que quieren
cruzar a Estados Unidos Andrés
bien una de las principales vías legales
que ha dispuesto el gobierno de Joe
biden es la aplicación móvil cvp One
aquí en Ciudad Juárez Las los miles de
migrantes que se encuentran varados en
una especie de Limbo todas las mañanas
ingresan a esta aplicación para
solicitar una cita en la cual le pueda
explicar a uno de los jueces Cuál es su
proceso de asilo porque está solicitando
asilo hay que tener en cuenta que muchos
de los migrantes acusan a sus países de
origen de ser o bien dictaduras o bien
regímenes y que no tienen opciones de
trabajo pero aquí Lo importante es que
ellos puedan demostrar que son
perseguidos políticos algo importante es
que a través de la aplicación cvp One
los migrantes quedan eximidos de la
nueva normativa que impuso el presidente
Joe biden esta semana de que los
migrantes que hayan cruzado diferentes
países varias fronteras pues no serán
elegibles otro de los importantes
centros o ayudas que se está esperando
para los migrantes es el de los centros
de recepción de migrantes en Guatemala y
en Colombia que también se podrían abrir
en Costa Rica y en Ecuador y allí
recepcionar entre 5.000 y 6000 casos de
solicitudes de asilo por mes